I'm Will Adamson and I am a group scout master and Timber Wolf pack leader with the 80th
Overmountain Scout Group in Abingdon, Virginia.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scout Master,
Before we get started this week, a warning: don't go camping in Itchy Coo Park.
Itchy Coo Park,
You heard me right? okay,
We were camping there last week. I don't know what it was, but everybody had the same dream.
I'm not kidding.
We all dreamt we were roasting giant marshmallows. and the next morning we got up and our tent
poles were all charred and our pillows were gone.
If you're old enough, you recognize that and I apologize.
10,000 bonus points to the first person who tells me who did that song. okay,
This is podcast number 247,. hey,
Hey, everybody, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Let's see. here
I had this email from someone who asked to remain anonymous, but they were commenting
on the series that we've been publishing for the past few weeks.
It's a fictional series about a new Scout Master.
If you haven't seen that, make sure to take a look at it over at scoutmastercgcom.
As somebody wrote in to say I'm truly enjoying your new Scout Master series.
I became a new Scout Master last year and the stories that are in the series are all too
familiar to me.
It mirrors my experiences, but unfortunately, the Scout Master in your story has a lot less
resistance to making the changes he's making than I did.
So in the end, my son and I found an excellent boy-led troupe that was closer to home.
Your podcast and website kept me going in the right direction.
While all situations can't be as ideal as your story, it was a good learning experience
for both my son and myself.
The one advantage I have in writing a fictional account, of course, is to make everything
come out okay,
And sometimes that just doesn't happen,
And I salute your dedication to the idea of scouting.
You gave it a good shot
And then you did something that a lot of people may not have done
And that is say: okay, you know, no harm, no foul.
You guys don't want to do scouting the way that I'm looking at it.
And you found another troupe.
Good for you and your son,
Because he's really the most important part of this right.
His interests are the most important part of it.
So I'm glad you got in touch with me about that
And I'm glad that things worked out ultimately for the good and that we could have a small
part in that.
Tennessee also. this week over on the blog I published a gift guide and it featured one
item that I heard from my old buddy, Tom Gillard, about down in Tallahoma, Tennessee,
And Tom wrote in to say I noted that you had fingerless rag-wool gloves in your gift
guide.
Are you sure that shouldn't be digit-impaired rag-wool gloves?
Thanks, Tom, I think.
Check out the gift guide.
I've published maybe three of them so far and I've got a couple others ready to go.
Just some ideas for scouts and scouters.
Sometimes we can be difficult to buy for
It can be a little bit of a challenge.
So I'm giving you some ideas out there.
I had a couple of great live chat sessions this week and let me see who checked in
with us.
We talked about lots of different things, about winter camping and all kinds of
great stuff.
George Z checked in with us and he's with Troop 767 in Broomfield, Colorado.
We heard from Dennis Unger in Watumka, Alabama, with Troop 13 and Pak 50.
And our frequent fliers checked in:
John Nelson from Ohio and Steve Cattrall from Michigan.
Rhonda Ruff-Wyman is a scout master and a district member in Missouri.
Bradley White-Fendison is out there in the Mojave Desert in 29 Palms, California.
Todd Lund is a scout master in Little Egg Harbor, Southern New Jersey,
And that makes Todd and I neighbors in a kind of strange continental sense, because I'm
in southeastern Pennsylvania.
Hi, Todd
Michael Menager is in the Foothill District of the Atlanta Area Council.
Assistant scout master Dave checked in with us from Lake Forest, California.
Scout master Sean, who's the scout master of Troop 1363 in Green Bay, Wisconsin.
Doug Boyce, who is the assistant scout master with Troop 103 in Wisconsin,
And I've been meaning to mention this. but Doug has a great website with a blog and
a podcast that are aimed at Cub Scouts
And to find his blog you're going to go to BrightideaScoutingcom
And it's B-R-I-T-E- Idea Scouting, all one word B-R-I-T-E IdeaScoutingcom.
I'll make sure to have a link in the post that contains this podcast,
But check it out.
Doug's doing a wonderful job over there
And I know that there's a lot of folks who are looking for Cub Scout specific information
And Doug would be a great source for you.
And finally, on the chat this week we heard from Merlin group scout leader over in the
Netherlands.
It was great to hear from him.
So, from coast to coast and around the world, a live chat.
Keep an eye on the Scout master's CG Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
And I will post when we're going to have live chats
And then come and sign in and join us-
Great fun.
Hey, did you notice this week's backer announcement?
Bill Adamson is a group scout master in Addington, Virginia, with a scout group in the B-P-S-A.
Did you get it?
B-P-S-A?
That's the Baden Powell Service Organization.
If you haven't heard of them, check them out at B-P-S-A-USorg-
Another one that I'll have a link to in the post that contains this podcast.
But the B-P-S-A is a program for people to do scouting in their community.
Looks great to me
And I've corresponded with several people involved with the B-P-S-A
And, as always, the majority of the people who listen to the podcast and read the blog
are from the United States.
Most of them are involved with the Boy Scouts of America, the B-S-A,
And some of the advice and the answers that you get from the podcast and on the
blog are organizationally specific policies and procedures.
But my aim is always to focus on those broad underlying concepts of scouting that
hopefully will apply wherever you are doing scouting and whoever you're doing it with,
And I want to thank Will for signing up and becoming a backer.
Now, if you're a regular reader and listener and the resources we have created
are helping you, you can return the favor by doing exactly what Will did
and become a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses of producing and publishing
the blog posts and the podcast and the videos and all the other stuff
that have become a valuable resource that are accessible to scouters all over the world.
It's easy to do. Here's what you do:
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose any level of support, and some of those entitle you to premiums
like autographed copies of my books.
And let me make sure to personally thank this week Paul Farley,
Carlton Scott and Dennis Unger, who all became ScoutmasterCGcom backers
since our last podcast.
So go to scoutmasterCGcom, click on the support link at the top of the page,
become a backer this week and I'll be sure to thank you during our next podcast.
Well, in this week's podcast in Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk a little bit about the tone and volume of your voice,
Of your voice. that's right.
It's about time we talked about that too.
Don't take that tone with me, Mr.
And then we have some email questions to answer,
So that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
Let's get started, shall we
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
You know, early on when I became Scoutmaster, I found myself yelling at my scouts.
Do you find yourself yelling at your scouts?
How about your youth leadership? or your fellow scouts?
Oh yeah, I've been there.
I know that sometimes things get frustrating or sometimes you have to get attention,
but yelling is really kind of an aggressive, authoritarian leadership thing. right,
It gets compliance, but it doesn't really get anything else.
I'm a big guy, especially when it comes to you know, in comparison with my scouts,
I can loom and I can be very intimidating,
And if I raise my voice that's doubly intimidating.
But raising my voice does not earn me respect, not at all.
It makes me into someone who's feared and disliked.
I mean, it's the lowest form of leadership, if you can even call it leadership,
And it reminds me of something that Baden Powell said in one of his writings.
He said: any ass can be a commander,
And I don't even have to comment on that.
I mean he had it down right.
There's a big difference between speaking loudly and yelling,
And let's define yelling as raising your voice and frustration or anger.
Now, speaking loudly is asking everybody to volunteer their attention,
And in scouting sometimes you're going to raise your voice
And you can do that in a friendly, kind and courteous attitude,
Something you can't do when you're yelling.
A lot of times you'll be able to use the convention of holding up the scout
sign and getting everybody's attention.
But if you're in a campsite or something like that,
or everybody's all spread out, sometimes you may have to raise your voice.
But we don't want to train our scouts to only respond to an adult
or a youth leader who yells.
And we don't yell at scouts because we have a much bigger job to do
than merely making them compliant. right,
We want good group discipline and that comes from a combination
of citizenship and loyalty,
And I think that's best developed in an atmosphere of voluntary obedience,
not obedience compelled by the threat of punishment or being yelled at.
Here's what I tell my youth leaders. right,
If the scouts are all distracted and squirrely and you need your attention,
you ask for their attention once and then you wait
If they don't respond right away- and they hardly ever do.
you just continue waiting.
This is what I tell my youth leaders. okay,
And let's. we're at a troop meeting, we're in a campsite,
we're in any situation. they need to get the attention of the guys
and their patrol. or maybe the senior patrol leader
needs to get the attention of the troop.
And you know a couple of guys, just
he just can't break through.
So I say you go and ask them this question:
Can you get with the program here
or do you need to go talk to the scout master?
So give them a choice. right,
They can get with what you're doing
or they can come and talk to me.
Any scout who gets referred to the scout master
gets to talk to me.
And if that same scout needs to come over
and talk to me on a regular basis about this,
well then we're gonna be getting their parents involved
and we're gonna be talking to them too.
But this discussion with your youth leaders
would help set the way forward.
You work together to arrive at an agreement
that nobody- no adult and no youth leader-
ever yells at anyone for any reason.
And once you've done this,
once you've kind of declared a yell-free zone
with your patrol leader's counsel,
then you may wanna make sure to share that with the scouts
so that they all understand,
And you wanna make sure to share that with the other adults.
This is a yell-free zone.
We're drawing a line
Now. if you make a bunch of rules,
you'll have to break them, make an agreement right
And then work within it
to best serve each individual scout.
Most of us have at least a couple of scouts
who are gonna find it really difficult to stay focused
And they may benefit from a little counseling now again,
They may need a little more leeway
as they start to get the handle
on their ability to concentrate or follow.
If you have a yelling problem in your troop,
look at the situations
that commonly cause people to yell.
It may be that you're painting yourself into a corner right.
Watch for situations where someone has to demand
the intention of the entire troop.
Scouting really doesn't work on that scale.
It's not designed to work on that scale.
It works on the scale of the patrol.
90% of the time a scout should be under the direction
of his patrol leader,
not just another face in a larger crowd.
And, as I've said many times,
we need to be careful about who dispenses discipline.
Youth leaders refer scouts
to the scout master for correction.
They never punish,
They don't yell at scouts,
They don't apply any aggressive,
authoritarian methods of discipline,
because scouts are boys,
and boys this age tend to go all Lord of the Flies
pretty quickly.
And if you don't know what the Lord of the Flies is,
well, Google it,
Look it up.
But no, it's basically a story told
about a group of boys
who end up shipwrecked on an island
and things don't go very well.
Minutes after you've declared a yell for your zone,
somebody's gonna yell.
It's predictable, right?
But don't jump all over them.
Go back to square one
and talk it through again
and again, and again.
Remember, we're looking for that voluntary obedience
that is the mark of good, loyal citizenship.
It's a rare commodity, isn't it?
In nearly every other situations,
your scouts find themselves
in their under of regime of rules and punishments.
Volunteering obedience is something new.
It requires a lot of thinking
and some real maturity on their part.
And remember, yelling gets you compliance,
but it doesn't get you voluntary obedience right.
You can raise your voice when you need to,
but we're not gonna yell at our scouts.
["In the Mountain Greenery, Where God Beings the Seemery"].
In the mountain greenery, where God Beings the Seemery.
When it rains we'll have for the weather
And if you're good, I'll search for wood
So you can cook while I stand looking.
We could find no cleanery treat from life's machinery
And our mountain greenery it's our mountain greenery.
Bless our mountain greenery home.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Hey, I heard from Bill Chapman,
who is the Scoutmaster of Troop 736
in Rancho Santa Margarita, California,
And he wrote in to ask me this question.
I just sent out one of the weekly troop emails
that parents and committee members
tell me they really appreciate.
It reminds them of the troop meeting,
upcoming campout, other special events,
things like that.
Now I'm feeling a little conflicted about doing this
because I would really rather
that the Scouts took care of this themselves
and that they wanted to know and ask questions
than me spoon-feeding them all this information
through this newsletter.
If I stop sending the newsletter,
my committee is not going to be happy.
I'll stop in arms already about the changes we're making
And I'm looking for a little advice about this.
Well, Bill, I get what you're saying about the newsletter,
but I don't think it's at cross purposes
with developing what you want to see in your youth leaders.
There's apples and oranges that we're dealing with here:
keeping parents and committee members informed
and having Scouts develop some leadership
and discovery skills.
Those are really kind of two separate things.
So as Scoutmasters we need to be rigidly flexible
and not too dogmatic.
One way to blend the apples and oranges in this situation
is maybe involving the Patrol Leaders Council
in helping you create that email newsletter. right,
But this is fraught with dangers
because if you totally hand it off to them,
it's going to become a writing assignment in their minds
and it's not going to go very far.
if you're a Scouts or anything like mine,
The best way, I think, is for you to collect their thoughts
and plans and translate them for the adults,
their parents and the committee members
through your newsletter,
which is probably what you're doing anyway.
It takes a lot of effort for any of us
to get a perspective on Scouting
that allows youth leadership
to actually have real responsibility,
And once you have that perspective,
you can help other people gain it
by translating what you see your Scouts doing
into something cogent for their families to understand.
Youth leaders, in my experience,
do not make those translations as well as you can.
They don't get into adult speak very well
and it's kind of distracting to ask them to do so
because they're busy doing other things.
Guide them through the discovery process
and then translate their conclusions into the newsletter.
Now, at the same time, I would offer to include
anything that they would like to write,
but I wouldn't necessarily make that an assignment.
You'll probably end up discovering a Scout
who shows some talent for this,
So you encourage it and capitalize on it.
I've had Scouts who were very, very good
at writing- you know- information
for the newsletter or emails
and who really enjoyed doing that.
But sometimes they don't
and that's a great thing to capitalize on.
So, in the end, keep sending out the newsletter-
It's a great idea.
Keep encouraging your youth leaders
to ask questions and find things out for themselves,
But remember that keeping parents informed,
keeping your committee informed
and having your Scouts really value that discovery process-
they can be two different things.
Bill had another question in that email
He said I just had a committee member
question my idea that we do some backpacking
because the Scouts will have to buy new, expensive equipment.
Well, on backpacking, Bill,
I would begin by shaping the experience
to what the Scouts have now.
Don't aim at backpacking trips
that require a lot of specialized gear. at this point,
You know, do a two or three mile hike in and camp
and build off of that.
If they don't have real, honest to goodness,
backpacking backpacks, ask around a little bit
and see if you can find a few-
because I know from experience there are plenty
sitting in attics and garages out there
that never get used-
And see if you can get things rolling that way.
The idea is shaping the experience.
that's easy, fun and encouraging
for the first few times out on a backpacking trip.
Now, if they really get into it,
if they really like the idea of backpacking,
you can start developing the whole thing incrementally.
I look at it this way:
If you gave somebody a six foot piece of bamboo
with a hook and a line tied on the end
and you go fishing for sunnies in the local creek
with a can of corn,
you can get them interested in fishing.
If you start with a thousand dollar fly fishing outfit,
you get them interested in fishing gear
rather than fishing. understand,
If you're going to go backpacking, go backpacking.
Use what you got,
Be adaptive and make it a short hike,
Get the guys interested in it
and then the gear follows
And not really the other way around.
I had this email
and I am keeping the sender anonymous.
I'm a district advancement chair
and assist with eagle boards of review.
Some of the folks I regularly call on
to help with boards
declined to be on the board
for one eagle candidate.
They tell me his parents were over-involved
in his project
and that they probably wrote his paperwork,
that he's rude to the other scouts
and leaders in his troop.
Knowing this information is only secondhand.
I appreciate any advice you have
on going to the board of review.
It sounds like he didn't really do very much
for eagle and that his parents
were really over-involved in the whole process.
So when we're talking about questions like this,
we talk about the guide to advancement 2013..
Make sure you look at the guide
to advancement 2013
and read all it has to say
about eagle boards of review,
Especially those directions that it gives
when a scout can't get
a fair hearing from his unit
and the steps for what happens next
if you have a board of review
and he doesn't pass that board.
As for the embryo surrounding the scout himself,
if you're a district advancement chair,
you're going to hear about things like this
from time to time.
Let's think through this for a moment.
First of all, there's only one way to earn eagle
and that's to complete the requirements.
The issue of exactly
how the scout completed the requirements
is one of the things the board
is going to judge.
Rumor and innuendos unsupported
by any evidence
ought to not to be discussed
by any board of review.
Otherwise, how could you give the scout
a fairer and objective hearing?
If some people refuse to sit on the board,
then ask other people.
You only need three total right.
There are two points that make this
demonstrably clearly
not the scout's fault.
First of all,
how did he get to the point where
he's going to have an eagle board of review
and get past the dozens of opportunities
to express concerns
and take actions about the things
that you've told me?
If he's ready for an eagle board of review,
he's completed eagle application
and he's completed his eagle project
and that means he's already secured
all of the required signatures
that indicate probably
the very people are complaining about him
have already approved of his work.
So let's think about this.
He's had a scout master's conference
for the rank of eagle
and somebody had to sign off on that conference.
It probably was the scout master.
His service in a position
of responsibility was already approved.
Somebody had to sign off on that.
He proposed, executed
and completed and reported
on an eagle scout project.
So that means his unit leader,
the troop committee chair,
the district advancement chair,
the project beneficiary have been following
this all along.
They've had to sign his eagle workbook
and that signifies
their approval of his work.
If you want to go back a little further,
he's had previous scout master conferences
and boards: a review
for tender foot,
second class, first class
star and life,
And for those last two he had to complete
leadership tenure for both of those ranks.
and the only way that happens
is if somebody signs off
their approval of all that work.
And let's remember
he also has the signatures of a minimum of
21 merit badge counselors
certifying his completion of the work
required to earn the merit badges
he needs for eagle.
So how could it possibly
be anything but a travesty
of unfairness
to ambush him at his border review
with questions that should
have been addressed when people
were signing off his
work before right?
These folks who have grave
concerns now should have brought
them up at the proper time
rather than signing off on his paperwork.
They've lost any opportunity
to object and it's absolutely
patently unfair for them
to ambush him at his border review.
So if you're going to conduct the border review,
I would do it as you would do any other.
I would make sure that you're not
poisoning the well by sharing any of
these rumors or innuendos
or making the slightest indication
to the other board members. you invite
that there's anything out of the ordinary.
The judgment of the board is based on
what's in the normal paperwork
and the board's discussion with the scout
during the review. Now if, in the course
of conducting the board, concerns
arise, then
you deal with them when they come up,
but don't be the source of innuendo
and rumor. that would
make it impossible to give this scout
a fair hearing. and the most
important thing here is the interest
of the individual scout in question.
Now let's suppose
that all these rumors and innuendos
that you've heard are true. Let's
suppose his parents were over
involved in everything that he ever did in scouts.
Let's suppose that he's
ill-behaved and he hasn't
satisfactorily fulfilled
his positions of responsibility, even though
people have signed them off. Let's just assume
the worst-case scenario, right,
If his parents were actually
over-involved, how is
this the scout's fault? Is it
within his power to overrule his parents?
And the answer is
always no.
You can't save scouts from their parents.
So what needs to happen is he needs
to have a border review and a fair hearing
that is not colored by a bunch
of rumors and innuendos.
If the members of that border review
discuss things with the
scout and that raises
concerns, you're going to cross that bridge
when you get to it. Your job
as a district advancement
chairman is assuring that
he has a fair,
objective review.
If anybody wants to make a case about this,
then just politely ask them
to point out to you in the Guide to Advancement
the provisions that permit them to make
waves. They won't be able to find
anything because it's just not fair
for the reasons that I've explained.
So we heard from Rob Kerrigan, who is
an assistant scout master with Troop 1
in the Pine Tree Council
in Portland, Maine,
And Rob has a seasonal question for us.
A Salvation Army board member
asked our scouts to help with bell ringing.
They're usually short on volunteers
this time of year, and so he reached out
to our troop. I checked the BSA
rules and regulations about this
and it says youth members shall not
be permitted to serve as solicitors
of money for their chartered
organization, for the local council
or in support of other
organizations. Adult
and youth members shall not be permitted
to serve as solicitors of money
in support of personal or
unit participation in local, national
or international events. For example,
Boy Scouts and Cub Scouts
and leaders should not identify
themselves as Boy Scouts or Cub Scouts
or, as a troop or pack,
participate in the Salvation
Army's Christmas Bell ringing
program. This would be raising
money for another organization.
At no time are units permitted
to solicit contributions
for unit programs.
So my question Rob
asked: can I still
ask the scouts if they want
to be involved in this
individually? If they did volunteer
their time to be bell ringers,
would this count towards their community
service for advancement? Well, Rob,
I should think that offering your scouts
the opportunity to serve as bell ringers would be fine,
so long as they aren't wearing
uniforms or in any way
representing the BSA scouting
or their troop. They're there
to help the Salvation Army
and they're doing that as a
good-hearted volunteer,
just like many of the other volunteer
opportunities that are open to them,
and I would think that that type
of service would definitely qualify
towards community service for rank
advancement. The principle involved here
is: scouts are never
asking for people to give
them a cash contribution,
and the same goes for adult leaders.
we are not permitted to
solicit cash contributions.
we can, and we certainly do,
volunteer our time to other organizations
where we may be soliciting
cash donations,
like the Salvation Army bell ringing
program, which would be fine to do,
so long as it's not representing
the BSA. Now,
with that advice in mind,
run it past your district
executive first, just to make sure that
I've got it right. As with
any advice I give about policies
or procedures for a specific scouting
organization, I'm doing my
best to figure it out, but
you check with the authorities and you
check and make sure that
the resources that we have available to
us back up my conclusions.
and if you have a difference of opinion,
get in touch with me. or if you have
another question that you'd like to have me answered,
you can get in touch with me, and you're going to find
out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thank you for listening
to this 247th
edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch:
go to scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
by email. you may think about joining
about 4,000 other mobile
scouters who have the Scoutmaster CG
app on their mobile devices.
you can get the app on
Google Play or in the iTunes App Store.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of
social media outlets.
you can join the 6600 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1100
tweeters on twitter.
pin the poultry to his pictures
proffered publicly, with
1800 other prolific pinners on
Pinterest. watch us at
scoutmastercg on youtube or,
of course, join the 400 odd
folks who follow us on google plus.
if you got no idea what I'm talking about,
if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better, if you have no interest
in Pinterest, maybe you don't put the
you in youtube. if you're a minus when it
comes to google plus, well, that's alright.
bunkie, zoom in to the late 90s
and send me an email.
I'm available at clark at
scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom,
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
the Boy Scouts of America or any other
scouting organization for that matter.
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
nope, it's just me
with a microphone and a laptop
and somehow the powers that be
allow me to access the internet,
so that, by the agency of the powerful internet
tubes, you're able to listen
to the dulcet tones of my voice,
which will conclude the podcast by saying:
we like to have a little bit of fun now and again.
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.